what he discovered as he opened me up is
that this one had fully ruptured the
right one and we actually did it near
Halloween and he posted it on his thing
it was like yellow like when you sent me
pictures of that I was like I think to
myself truly I drove 200 miles an hour
and hit walls and I literally had one
checked in an MRI
like in 2018 because it was hard and I
thought maybe it's ruptured and
everything was fine so I'm like how does
this happen like how does the silicone
just sort of like
fail as we know transdermal works so
like your scar tissue is still seeping
and leaching like there's no way it's
not a it's not concrete you know so
that's uh did the doctor say that that
was a really dangerous situation he was
basically just like I haven't seen this
in five years and then you know I was
grateful that my body encapsulated it
but like you said you know there's still
stuff that's happening you know and I
don't I didn't even ask him about mold
you know what what was going on there if
it's if it's ruptured like Lord knows
what's seeping through my body so I
definitely want to do
um some sort of like detox and cleansing
protocol just do some testing then that
way you know I mean sometimes people
test things and they're totally fine and
that hopefully is the case but yeah
those tests are really easy it was a
godsend and I don't know how my body did
it and my body protected me my body is
so intelligent but Lord knows how that
thing ruptured I mean what like was it
the pressure of bread the breast milk I
don't I don't know what have you noticed
after have you noticed anything or or is
it more just like uh you know what what
have you enjoyed about it if you like
symptom-wise I'm curious but then also
just like energetically you know where
were you at and what were you feeling
needed to shift and then what are the
little things that you notice now that
you're like oh my God that's great yeah
I just feel
there's just like a lightness of being
and a back to myself so
it's just a lighter load and you know
I've had like upper right shoulder neck
problems which is the side that had
ruptured
um so I think there was a lot of like
muscle tension that was also like
protecting me too so that I think is
going to be able to release more and
more which and that's been just chronic
for years you know probably
enhanced by the implant so
um I mean that alone is a game changer
of quality of life because that's it's a
constant like I feel like I have a bag
of rocks on my on my back so I think
that that is all able to unwind and
and I just feel like I don't know I just
feel like I can open my heart more you
know even again like you want to be more
proportionate you want to be more
womanly but then you subconsciously know
that there's some inauthenticity here so
you kind of like hunch you kind of you
don't you know you don't at least I
didn't I was a little bit like
protective too of being too womanly you
know it's like you can never hit it just
right so uh just having that whole
narrative and whole thing gone
and it's a journey I don't like beat
myself up I don't it was like that's
where I was at 12 years ago here I am
today and and I also think it's so
interesting too as we see
there's just different I think it's just
like also
not to name any like celebrity families
or anything but like a lot of people are
getting butt implants and boobs and lips
and can you imagine sitting on implants
I mean I've laid down in yoga or for a
massage and I'd lay down and I'd be like
ah these things are annoying and they
were 200 CC's can you imagine sitting
your ass down with ass implants I just
can't I can't I've just always thought
the goal was to get a smaller ass I
agreed I go into the gym and I'm like I
don't want a bigger butt okay I don't I
don't want a bigger butt
so hamstrings it is but there's a whole
culture that likes a bigger butt and
those women thought that that was more
womanly you know I just I don't know I
don't know so Barbie proportions not to
call anyone out that there was a picture
of like Barbie and someone and like how
the body was shaped the same and I'm
like it's not [ __ ] real but I think
that there's an unwinding of that now
too and people are going back to a more
I don't know this certainly feels right
for me and I'm just also at a different
place in my life where I'm more about
who am I authentically and less
searching for any sort of feedback or
validation from the outside world and
more just like what makes me feel good
what do I want to express
you know and it took me 43 years to get
to this point
um and you have to just go along the way
so that was just part of the journey I
do think that it's appropriate for in
the spirit of implants to go back in
time to like just explain like why you
did it you know like when did you do it
and why did you do it totally
so 12 years ago I guess 2010
I had always I'd never like thought
about getting implants but I'd always
been self-conscious of my shoulders
um just proportionally like I was pretty
proportioned kid but people always
commented you know are you a swimmer
your shoulders are so big my arms were
just big you know that was my perception
and
um and then I was pretty flat ultimately
I just wanted to be in proportion you
know I wanted to feel like a woman as I
went through this whole journey of
making the decision you know because you
inspired me to do so which is so awesome
I was
um thinking back I was like trying to do
the whole healing process of like what
what really got me to do it I mean in
2010 it was because I was sick of being
out of proportion and I wanted to feel
more feminine but what what was it back
in the day and I remember this boy that
I'm still friends with today he was like
my first love
it was in eighth grade eighth to ninth
grade and he made I think it was in
eighth grade and he made a comment about
how flat I was because everybody around
me was you know going through puberty I
was a much later Bloomer and
you know back like looking back it means
nothing to me but I remember being
absolutely devastated
and then you know I went like I went
through puberty probably two three years
after most of my girlfriends and he had
a girlfriend at the time who had gone
through puberty in eighth grade and
is the thief of Joy exactly so Joy
ripped from me and then you know there
was just this subconscious little trauma
that I had suppressed so at the time I
and I and I was an actor at the time and
so I remember telling my surgeon please
I don't want big boobs I just want shape
it was more of just like I was a full
bee but I I but they were just like they
weren't they were just not doing
anything they weren't perky they weren't
doing anything so I was like I just want
a little more shape and to be more
proportionate and so before I went under
I was like I know you tell me I want
more I don't want more I'm I'm blonde if
you give me bigger boobs I'm going to
just be Typecast as a bimbo and that's
the end of my career so
um so I got really small implants how
small were they I had 213 that's what
mine were yeah I think mine was around
that too that's not big right no no it
most most don't go much under 300. yeah
I think mine was like somewhere like 210
to 220. yeah that's pretty small so you
have the same set so you only ever had
one set only had one set 12 years I
remember someone tell they were silicone
this is before the FDA banned silicone
or did you somehow get silicone I can't
remember the years but they did remember
when they banned silicone for a while
because it wasn't it wasn't uh it was
banned because it was not it was
unhealthy and I I remember thinking of
myself I'm like oh that's stupid
somebody obviously won in some like
money War battle like yeah I don't know
I just remember people saying silicone
was softer and I wanted really natural
and even though I was like healthy
minded at the time not like I am today
um it was still a bad aesthetic for me
so I was just like I don't care if
saline safer I want I want him to feel
real did you even know silicone to be
unsafe I knew there were risks I knew
that there if if it if they leaked into
your body that you could have some toxic
reaction and you didn't want them to
leak and that's why this is is like the
basic due diligence that I did
um silicone has more risk than saline
because if somehow they leaked which is
very unlikely it could be toxic to your
body but you would know and then you
could get them removed and it wouldn't
be like tragic I didn't realize until I
just took them out that I got like the
silicone gel like they had and maybe
this was after it was banned and then
they came back with this gel that was
less likely to leak so I knew there was
like this 10-year expiry but then I also
knew people that had their implants in
for 20 years I was like skirt by for a
couple years you're gonna be fine then I
had a child and then I breastfed and
thank God I was still able to breastfeed
that was my biggest worry but after you
breastfeed you lose a lot of tissue so
then I started to feel in the last
couple years I started to feel the
implants in me even though they're small
but I had I could feel and I was like
okay I gotta get them out and then I saw
your your story and your and I was like
okay I'm ready to do this let's do this
I think I grew up in the Victoria's
Secret age you know we had I I was have
born in 1979 so in the 80s and early 90s
it was like the supermodels were all
kind of Victoria's Secret models that
song have you heard that song the
Victoria's Secret Song I don't think so
oh my God you have to hear the
Victoria's Secret song it's basically
saying Victoria was made up by a dude in
Ohio Les Waxman is made up by a dude in
Ohio there she's not real and I was like
oh my God that's so true so true exactly
so it's this unrealistic I ideal of the
woman that you know every guy
you know and Playboy that kind of pin up
proportion never appealed to me but like
the bikini model svelte but still curvy
some of it was natural some of it was
not many much of it was airbrushed so
again unrealistic and that was just what
I grew up thinking was the ideal for men
you know and then when you are in your
late 20s early 30s and
you know things aren't working out in
love or acting you just like want to
make a change and you're like well this
is the problem this is the one area I'm
not proportionate you know or whatever
it's it's so silly to look back on when
I got them I wanted to feel more womanly
as well and when I like when a guy grabs
it there ain't nothing there okay and
then I was like ah and then they felt
him and I was like oh my God now I just
think about the fact that they're fake
like it didn't even work and you know
then they they come out and I still feel
you still have reasons for to feel
insecure if it's not my boobs it's my
butt if it's not my butt it's my abs if
it's on my abs it's my legs like it just
found another place to be unhappy I I
mean that's what I found so you know
like systemically I feel like it's more
of a root cause so do you feel like it
solved your problems or do you feel like
it just transferred 100 percentages
transfers you know and it's and and this
is the journey that I'm on this is a
journey I think we all are on is to to
get to a place where we can fully accept
every aspect of ourselves and our psyche
and now I mean I love having them out
like you said like you wanted
you wanted to be more womanly and
proportionate but then when there was
actual intimacy and interaction with
them you're like
I'm saying you know and I've like made
sure I did like the doctor like after
you get implants in you're supposed to
like move them so they don't get hard
and get encapsulated and so I did like
twice as much I was like forget the pain
like I'm making these girls natural you
know but you're still self-conscious
when with intimacy because you're like
there's and you're like there's gonna be
a little bit of a
because you know they're not real if you
like this clip and you want to hear the
whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen